zurück bei bild live mit bildern von
diesem gewaltigen raketen einschlagen
bilder die wenige minuten alt sind und
die spielen im herzen von prag have der
zweitgrößten stadt in der ukraine eine
millionenstadt eine studentenstadt
russland beschießt das zentrum der stadt
gezielt mit schweren raketen ja das ist
ein ziviles gebäude das regionale
verwaltungsgebäude regierungsgebäude
dort mit dieser riesigen explosion man
kann förmlich live zustehe sehen wie
hier zivilisten sterben genaue zahlen zu
opfern gibt es derzeit noch nicht wie
gesagt diese bilder sind ganz ganz
frisch gerade reingekommen wir wollen
darüber sprechen hier im studio mit
unserem experten max kiewel max wenn du
diese bilder siehst was steckt
möglicherweise dahinter welche art von
rakete also ich glaube wir müssen erst
mal dass beim namen nennen was wir da
sehen das ist die nächste stufe in
diesem krieg vor der wir immer gewarnt
vor der wir alle angst hatten putin der
gezielt zivile gebäude bombardiert mit
raketen beschießt denn das jetzt hier
sind spektakuläre aufnahmen wir sehen
ein feuerball wir sehen eine rakete aber
vor allem sterben dort menschen menschen
die wir vor kurzem noch auf dem weg zur
arbeit waren die im auto fahren die in
dieses gebäude gehen und die dann
innerhalb von einer sekunde nicht mehr
leben weil putin weil seine soldaten
sich entschieden haben dieses gebäude
mit einem mehrfach raketenwerfer
anzugreifen und wir sehen uns am ende
von diesem gebäude nicht viel übrig
bleibt das ist im herzen der stadt
drumherum sind parks universitätsgebäude
das eben das regionale regierungsgebäude
dort wie glaubst du diese neue
eskalationsstufe wie wir die sich jetzt
entwickeln in den firmen stehen also das
war etwas ich habe es gesagt wovor wir
alle angst hatten dass der nächste
schalter umgelegt wird das noch
gezielter noch tödlicher bombardiert
wird dass ihr bilder von gestern die wir
hatten da ist eine große wohnsiedlung
beschossen auch in recke da wird alles
in dieser millionenstadt das sind das
hier kampfjets die feuer am himmel waren
das alles schief das ist fast so wie
eine eine blaupause der geschaffen wird
für die menschen in kiew schaut euch
genau anschaut was wir hier machen dann
wisst ihr was bei euch passieren wird
noch ein bisschen weiter östlich ja noch
ein bisschen weiter richtung russland
aber schaut euch an was wir hier machen
und dann seht ihr was wir bei euch in
kiew machen weder von der zerstörung
dort sagst es nach diesem gestrigen
kriegstag fünf schauen wir uns nochmal
an ausgeht also max diese stadt
strategisch etwas leichter zu erreichen
für putins truppen relativ nahe an der
russischen grenze und jetzt eben die
bilder von dort verwaltungsgebäude in hp
vor wenigen minuten schwer getroffen von
dieser rakete und wisst ihr was diesen
diese diesen krieg in kharkiv noch
unerträglicher macht das ist eine stadt
die zum großen teil aus russisch
stämmigen menschen besteht dort greift
putin man kann das so sagen seine
eigenen brüder oder wie auch immer an
menschen die noch weniger verstehen
werden warum sie plötzlich ins visier
seiner raketen gekommen sind dass uns
mag es auch über diese bilder sprechen
eine russische militär konvoi auf dem
weg nach kiew diese bilder sind in der
nacht um die welt gegangen eine
russische militär konvoi 64 kilometer
lang gesichtet kurz vor der hauptstadt
vor panzer artillerie logistik
truppentransporter all das 64 kilometer
lange strecke etwa wie von köln nach
dortmund ausschließlich aus
militärfahrzeugen das sind bilder die
zeigen es droht furchtbar zu werden in
kiew in den nächsten tagen
möglicherweise schon es ist eine
großoffensive auf die hauptstadt diese
bilder zeigen den plan der nächsten
großen putin schlacht max kiewel
militärexperte hier bei uns im studio
man sieht diese bilder die erste frage
die eigentlich im kopf schießt ist jetzt
hat man die wahl quasi auf dem
präsentierteller durch diese
satellitenbilder warum reagiert die
ukraine da nicht ganz schnell muss
vielleicht erst mal sagen dieser konvoi
wir beobachten den schon seit eigentlich
gestern nachmittag da hieß es 3 meilen
lang dann gestern abend 17 meilen und
jetzt ist ja noch mal so deutlich
angewachsen also wir sehen hier eine
ganz klare bewegung und wir sehen dass
dieser konvoi anwächst ihr habt das
gesehen unterschiedliche fahrzeuge
unterwegs in diesem konvoi und die große
frage ich sag es mal ganz glatt warum
wird dieser kontrolle nicht platt
gemacht bevor er in kiew so viel tod und
vernichtung anrichten kann und da gibt
es unterschiedliche erklärungen für
eventuelle hier die russen diesmal mit
eigener ja sozusagen mit eigenen schutz
elementen dabei also etwas was zum
beispiel drohen oder kampfjets abwehren
könnte oder eben die ukraine noch nicht
in der lage so weit zu kommen dahin
vorzustoßen wo dieser konvoi jetzt ist
aber ganz klar dahin wird die welt dahin
werden die nato-staaten die russen und
ukrainer genau schauen denn dieser
konvoi das ist womöglich der
entscheidende faktor in den nächsten
stunden und tagen für kiew für eine
schlacht bereitet sich putin dort vor
sein plan b nachdem der erste offenbar
nicht aufgegangen ist es ging nicht
schnell wir sehen bilder von
dramatischen russischen verlusten rundum
kilo schwere verluste zerstörte
militärkonvois ebendort getöteter
soldaten das heißt max das hat erst mal
nicht funktioniert der plan von putin
ganz schnell in die hauptstadt ihr
vorzudringen der hat nicht funktioniert
dass bilder von kiew ebendort wladimir
putin scheint sich katastrophal
verkalkuliert zu haben vielleicht weil
er seine eigene lügen und seine eigene
propaganda geglaubt hat seine rede davon
dass die ukraine kein echter start ist
dass die menschen dort sich nicht als
ukraine führen das beweisen sie ihm
gerade in jedem gefecht genau das
gegenteil und diese kurze präzise
nadelstiche das sozusagen zu einem
schnellen kapitulation von kiew geführt
hätte diese strategie ist nicht
aufgegangen und jetzt muss man womöglich
die strategie ändern muss diesen riesen
konvoi ins feld führen und dann wird
sich zeigen inwiefern überhaupt die
russischen truppen fähig sind so schnell
sich umzustellen was das bedeutet die
einkesselung einer 2 3 millionen stadt
was unser kollege paul ronzheimer von
beschwert hat das ist unbegreiflich das
ist etwas was es in der moderne nicht
geben darf was erkennst du darauf auf
den bildern erkennst du das spezifisch
was das für militärfahrzeuge sind sein
könnten du hast du hast vorhin schon
genau richtig geschildert wir sehen hier
alles wir sehen lkws mit versorgung wir
sehen haubitzen die artillerie geschosse
aus großer entfernung schießen können
wir sehen die klassischen russischen
panzer hier ist wirklich alles unterwegs
sind alles auf der straße und ja das ist
das ist das ist schrecklich und tödlich
was wir da sehen und was da eben auf dem
weg nach kiew ist ein einschätzungen
nach reicht diese kolonne aus um denn
der plan auch wirklich durchzusetzen um
kiew komplett einzukesseln und
geschlossen zu halten ich glaube das
wissen wir alle in dem moment noch nicht
auch weil wir alle überrascht sind ob
dell
heldenhafte taten der ukraine dieses
unglaublichen mutes sich dieser
übermacht entgegenzustellen aber dass da
das ist schon sehr erdrückend und ich
frage mich schon wie lange wir als
westen am ende aushalten werden wenn
dieser konvoi einstellung geht dieser
konvoi die menschen aus hungert keine
medizin kein essen und dazu raketen auf
zivilisten wie lange wir das als westen
aushalten werden ich habe das große
fragezeichen